as promised from the athletic as well as
Fox Sports none other than Bruce Feldman
back here on the program how are you
Bruce I'm doing well rich gonna be
ologist so what what happened in Ohio
State was this planned what can you tell
me about Urban Meyer deciding to step
down and retire as head coach of the
Ohio State you know rich there were
rumblings about it people who were
pretty close to her band I'm pretty
plugged-in so I'm thought there was a
good chance this would happen not work
with Chris Carter he's close to him and
he had told people that this was going
to happen you know on Saturday night
before our Fox had the Big Ten title
game and I had done a big shutdown with
Urban Meyer earlier in the week and
afterwards i sat down with rob stone as
our host and he had asked me where do
you think he is after this and I said
you know just that it's just like Urban
Meyer is a big go go with his gut guy
and I think things swirl with him and go
in all sorts of directions and I will
say this on Monday when we sat down he
wasn't the best movie I'd I'd ever seen
him in he was downright chipper which is
not a word I would normally used to
describe his you know him but he all he
wanted to talk about was this next game
Northwestern everything was steered
towards that and then it was like I
think he had come to a decision in his
head you know physically he had been
struggling all year obviously there was
a ton of stress a lot of that certainly
something self-induced with with the
zachsmith
situation how he handled that I think
that started a lot of it and now you
know we'll see if he ever coaches again
I don't know I mean he's still only 54
years old we we've seen this from him
before with his accident Florida so you
know I mean I think it's tough for a lot
of people to go yet he's done coaching
just because we've heard that before
from oh yeah I know so that's tough to
ask you the legacy question what his
legacy is because as you pointed out he
left Florida over health concerns went
to ESPN was actually a terrific analyst
there before getting the job at Ohio
State which you know was
I would say his dream job even though
when he was at Utah there was a
conversation about Notre Dame being a
great job for him or a dream job for him
and he's talking right now at Columbus
so I'm wondering if you really deep down
think that he is in fact uncoachable our
to predict on this I mean look
he sits out a year and then what happens
clay Hill who's been on the hot seat
then all of a sudden another huge job
could come open and fall right into his
lap I I don't know I mean you know he is
he is 10 years older basically than he
was last time out and further along is
like he's a grandfather now so maybe
this time it's different I don't know
there you know with Urban Meyer out
there though there are potentially out
there there are gonna be some people
looking at it going you know this is and
this is what I'm getting to do as part
of his legacy he is the second best
coach of his generation and then guy
he's second to his Nick Saban is the
best college football coach in the
history of the sport so you know what he
had a remarkable amount of success there
was a lot of drama around it but at the
end of the day I mean his winning
percentage home is is staggering and so
I'm very curious to see how this is
gonna unfold going forward I'm sure see
already how he explained some of this to
because you know we had seen all the
shots of him on the sideline looking
like he's an excruciating pain he's had
the the brain cyst that he had an
operated on before whenever I had talked
to him specifically about it he kind of
deferred some of those questions and he
said you know well you know that's for a
later time to really delve into that he
did say that he addressed some of it
earlier in the year just because felt
like he was getting tired of questions
well the questions are gonna keep coming
we'll see how he handles them this time
around and how pup were coming he really
wants to be at this time Bruce Feldman
Fox Sports the athletic joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show and the questions
won't always be for open jobs and the
top college jobs or even the NFL I mean
with the Cleveland Browns having an
opening
Baker Mayfield right there I mean
there's gonna be a lot of conversation
on that front just in the immediate term
and it would be difficult for him to
retire from Ohio State and then turn
around and show up in Cleveland but all
that said please wouldn't you also say
that it would be hanging over Ryan Day
now that Ryan Day takes over Bruce yeah
absolutely and that is the shadow that
he's gonna leave behind and how close to
it and and who knows but I mean in a
little bit I don't say the situation's
aren't that some water but Oklahoma had
a transition Bob Stoops walked away it
was a more of a quick turnaround Bob
Stoops almost the same point in his life
in his mid-50s decided to walk away now
I think Bob Stoops is coming back to
coaching that I don't see but Urban
Meyer's there he's followed by a guy who
was a young in his 30s offensive coach
who by all accounts is really brilliant
offensive mind
Lincoln Reilly's done terrific with the
transition I think Ryan Dale do really
well he's turned down opportunities he
could have been an offensive coordinator
with the Tennessee Titans last year he
could have had a real good shot to be
the head coach in Mississippi State
didn't want to do that has had other
opportunities in this coaching cycle
because I think he knew that there was a
decent chance this was going to happen
so you know look there's a lot of talent
that's the Ohio State they have
recruited at a high level and you know I
think there's no the infrastructure of
similar to what Lincoln Riley heard it a
lot of those same people who put the
product on the field are still gonna be
there in Columbus few more minutes left
with Bruce Feldman of Fox Sports in the
athletic with the Green Bay Packers job
open what are the odds that the Michigan
Ohio state rivalry loses both its head
coaches right now there's a lot of
rumors flying out there that the Packers
might be interested in Jim Harbaugh
wondering if you think that the the
interest might be mutual I could see
them being interested here's the thing
though rich and you know you know Jim
Harbaugh is better than I do the
ultimate competitor how does he leave
without beating because our schools are
tribal the work is not done I mean to me
that's that like I you know if you're
the ultimate competitor
about everything we know about Jim
Harbaugh he is that how does he walk
away from Michigan with that I don't see
that well I mean the only way that it
would be is if the feeling would be
mutual with Michigan I don't hear that I
don't think there's any some I don't
think the feelings gonna be mutual I
mean it wasn't like there were four and
eight I mean they were not into yeah
they got nothing I got drilled by I
admission by their archrival but still
you know I just don't see to me that's
waving the white flag and I don't know
who you're gonna get who's Michigan
gonna gonna turn around after you went
through the Jim Harbaugh stuff on you
know gladly forced him out of ten into I
think you can do better I don't even I
have no idea I don't even want to think
that I'm just asking you a few you're
hearing anything
on that time nah not on that front I
think that's I think probably that's
wishful thinking of some people who are
probably a little tired of Jim Harbaugh
but I'd be surprised if he would exit
that way I just don't that just doesn't
seem to be the way he's wired
what about Lincoln Riley in that spot
and my gut on this is Lincoln Riley
knows he's gonna have NFL opportunities
for a long time he knows he has the best
ad in college sports and Joe Castiglione
he's gonna have to make some tough
decisions and probably hire a new
defensive coordinator he'll find a new
quarterback Oliver is gonna go play
baseball but look I mean or he just had
he just had one Heisman winner it was a
good chance he's gonna have a second one
I think he stays in college for a while
he's got a young family I think they
stay in Mormon you know even if the star
comes calling this is the Green Bay
Packers though Brewers I mean you could
sit there and back and say you're gonna
have NFL opportunities but for the Green
Bay Packers I mean I don't
Roger mule Lincoln Raleigh's from he
will shoot Texas I'm not sure he grew up
saying I want to be the Green Bay
Packers head okay okay no so I look I
think there's you know the success level
he has he's gonna he's in his mid 30s he
is gonna have a chance to get some big
NFL job pretty much whatever he wants it
I think you're saying the Cowboys that's
what he's he'll just sit back and wait
for whenever Jerry names I know some of
the big
cowboy people are people that he knows
and he's connected to so to me that
would make more sense of him going up
and going up to Lambeau I mean Mike
McArthur was a toll taker in Western PA
so I don't know if he dreamed about
being the Packers head coach too but
what an opportunity that's sitting right
there he was yeah but I think what's
different is Mike McCarthy had come up
through that path and he wasn't he
wasn't a head coach at Oklahoma when
that happened mm-hmm that's true
Bruce Feldman last seconds with you here
on the show you mentioned a very good
chance that Lincoln Riley is coaching a
back-to-back Heisman Trophy quarterback
do you really think Kyler Murray has
zoomed past to uh and Dewayne Haskins
the last three weeks I said this on the
show yesterday with Michael Wilbon you
know what he did in Maryland the
pressure was on the defense wasn't
stopped and Maryland which as you know
is his hometown home area everybody was
hoping that he would go play football at
Maryland and he balled out than what he
did against Michigan followed by the Big
Ten championship game is a hell of a
closer on his resume what do you think
of this Heisman race Bruce I think it's
I think it's a great Heisman race I
think what you have right now is it's
about as close as I can remember three
guys being I'll say this the way I felt
about the Heisman going into the weekend
flipped on its head I thought it was
pretty close going in and I think it was
close coming out but you know we're not
supposed to reveal our ballots so look
until that point I'll just say this I
think it'll be really really close it
wouldn't shock me up to a wins because I
think a lot of people were leaning in
that direction beforehand but I think
Saturday changed a lot of people's minds
okay and you think they got the college
football for right Bruce I do I don't
think you can put you know they lost by
29 at Purdue's and unknown on ranked
Purdue they sputtered all over the place
they played one really good game at the
end of the year with our a game Oklahoma
you know they avenge their only loss and
they did it I think you know pretty
impressively against a pretty good team
and Georgia has two losses I'm sorry I'm
one of them's by 20 points the games
the matter they have no matter how you
play all right Bruce um really
appreciate the time thanks for joining
the show on a day where it's it was you
know expected but still surprising to
hear Urban Meyer's no longer to be coach
at Ohio State do you think and last
question for them I'm being serious here
do you think if Michigan had finally
broken through with Jim Harbaugh against
him that he would have stepped away then
and know under those circumstances I do
think he would have stepped away but I
think he would have been a lot less less
pleasant when I don't you wouldn't have
dealt with him you would have dealt you
were to sat down with Jim Harbaugh you
know I think this would have been
probably a lot different the way it's
being framed to be honest this press
conferences benefit
Bruce appreciate the time thanks so much
we'll chat down the line sounds great
thank you guys that's Bruce Feldman Fox
Sports and the athletic here on the
Richardson show of the day Urban Meyer
steps down at Columbus the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience